Volcanoes are unpredictable forces of nature
and there are about 1,500 geologically active
ones around the world.
Let that sink in.
This one, Bárðarbunga in Iceland, spewed
thousands of cubic feet of molten lava from
a crack in the earth’s crust back in 2014.
But by volcanologists standards, that was
considered a peaceful eruption.
Peaceful…
Huh.
Bárðarbunga could erupt explosively again
one day, shutting down air travel and unleashing
a level of environmental destruction that
would wipe out roads, homes, and daily life
as we know it.
Active volcanoes like this one exist all over
the world, but “active” is sort of a misnomer…
An active volcano can erupt at any time, but
it could also not.
That’s the nature of these bubbling cauldrons.
They’re incredibly dangerous and mystifying...
and so hard to predict.
Scientists are working hard to figure out
when a volcano is going to erupt .So the best
we can do now is whittle a prediction down
to a series of probabilities and best guesses…
And to do this, volcanologists have a few
things in their tool kit: seismometers that
can pinpoint the rise and fall of magma, thermal
imaging to detect the heat around a volcano,
and chemical sensors that sniff for volcanic
gases like sulfur and CO2.
Even with all of these data points, there’s
still no volcano forecast.
No one can say “this will erupt in X days.”
As they work toward getting a forecast, scientists
are adding another tool to their kit: seismic
noise interferometry.
It’s like listening to the “whispers”
of a volcano.
[VOLCANO SOUND]
Let’s break that down.
In a study, researchers analyzed seismic noise
moving through the volcano Kilauea in Hawaii
over a four year period.
Seismic noises are low-level vibrations in
the Earth; they come from earthquakes, ocean
waves, or in this case, magma swirling inside
a volcano.
By using seismic noise interferometry, the
researchers measured the speed of seismic
activity moving through a volcano.
They were able to record how fast the vibrations
were traveling and isolated the noise or “whispers”
coming from inside.
By isolating the seismic noise, scientists
were able to identify the sounds that indicate
an increase in internal pressure, which is
a warning sign for a future eruption.
Going one step further, the researchers compared
those results to a second set of data which
measured the bulging and shrinking of a volcano’s
summit over time.
Kilauea is a very active volcano.
As the pressure in its magma chamber increases
and decreases, it is constantly bulging and
shrinking.
This makes it a prime candidate for this kind
of research.
The researchers found a correlation between
the speed of this volcano’s seismic energy
and its bulging and shrinking.
As the magma fills up, it causes an increase
in pressure, which produces much faster seismic
waves.
And volcanoes tend to bulge up and out before
an eruption.
So, by combining these two data sets, researchers
were able to more accurately predict when
an eruption could happen.
Technical improvements like these are bringing
volcanologists one step closer to understanding
the inner workings of these explosive mountains
and the behaviors that lead to a massive eruption.
We’ve still got more work to do, but predicting
chaos is getting that much more precise.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain dot
com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Volcanoes spew lava at 1000 degrees Celsius
on earth, but did you know there are volcanoes
out in our universe that spew ice?!
Learn more about galactic ice volcanoes here.
And have you ever visited a volcano or want
to one day?
Let us know in the comments and subscribe
for more Seeker. Thanks for watching.